.
ABL
ISA FORM
PRAYOUCR I
CILY COMES TE AG MEAN ANNTAIEXA
ACT AND  INVOLVED  A
LIKEGE.
A AT FOCUSESMI
T ISBSTRUCTI SSO IF ONE OF MY C
N OFSSIBLE THAT THEY UD
SOMETHING EL IS AN  GOVERNMENT
SION B ETHING
OBSTRUCTION RELATED  POTPPLICA
SEIZE SOME5 BOXEUGHT THEY HAD D
T  LEO IT.TH
>> YEAH, I THIWHATERE,S TH
JUST BCUSECURING THEEA SUBPOENDA
MAL . OTHER POSSIBILITIN
HI
WHITE HOOR
NTES
IS'V, AT
OHY
WHWO
HAVETION R IT WASLASSIFNOT?
WHAT IS YOUR
WHY  T I DOLLAR
IOCUTYT INDAIF YOU'RE NO LONGEES
VERYARD TO UNDERSTANECT THRNMEN
OMATERIALO OK
MATERIALDISCERN WHETHEORTH TLE
WAI THINK AT
PAGORN
I WILL SAY ITHIAL CH
FOR WHY HE
HE I
REASHAVE HW YORE THE LEG A LITT
THDICTN OF THE
FOY HANDLINGC T A MINI
OCUMENTS? IIL
NG COULD STIPPRSR PRESIDENT.
EXRT
SEEM BVEBLEMATIC
HE FORMER PRESIDENT OF T
UND TO TREAT
HIS FLORID NEAERIALSRON  K
POOL.A REAL PROBLEM I,  MPERSPEV
SUSPECTO
WELL.
AV
ORVESTOR QUESTHOW MANY EYEBALLSA
FIPRT THATSIGNIFICANT INVEAT ER
OR NOT T D
.
BECAUSE THEYEAY  KNOWING WHO WAS
ANERHAIGN ADVERSARIES
LIKE CHINESE AND SO FORTH TOMAA
SAFE PLACE